hello I don't know when you're gonna
call so when would I sleep when I'm not
calling no it's not unreasonable at all
excuse me take it the boss lady's on a
warpath this morning I really think I
could help this company you just gave me
a chance just concentrate on being my
assistant where you always mean I got
big and I got rich so now we're gonna
check me boo I wish you were my age and
I check you I wish you were little I
told you watch it you want to bet
groaning look up that's for white people
cuz black people don't have the time
Child Protective Services enrolled this
child in school or somebody is going to
jail somebody do you mean shorten
everyone else you're a child so you have
to start acting like it get back to work
whose child is this walking around here
to tiny pink pants super babies all
across the world I need you to cover for
me in the office
I should really dress the part your body
gets into my clothes this is squad
lottie's that body looks like babyGap
Gymboree ass gospel gosh to me body damn
girl lookin like cookie from Empire
there's your teacher I could tell that
you are a special young lady I feel I
could get really I feel like I get you -
so you feel what I'm feeling no I'm not
feeling that at all don't don't look at
me like that
you just look look look at the other way
look through it look the look up there
what is going on well I'm April think
you're the boss of me think one more
thing I dare you you're too fast for
that skirt okay see I've been looking at
you like a little girl but you a
grown-ass woman we have a BMW situation
black mama whooping your kids mom you're
my mama
you